[Applause]
oh
excuse me I'm right
all righty then happy happy Thursday
everyone it's official this is now the
best late night show in America
it's the only late night show in America
I'll take it I don't care so today
senior Intel officials testified on
Capitol Hill on worldwide threats among
the topics China Russia Iran artificial
intelligence and also Geraldo removing
his shirt in front of children
discussion as some of our biggest most
dangerous adversaries so you'd think
we'd put someone serious in charge of it
right someone with gravitas and a
piercing intellect someone who can
assure America that everything's under
control so who'd we pick
what do you want to know I want to give
you I want to give you the opportunity
yeah it makes sense every time I hear
the words artificial intelligence I
think of her
but it's true Kamala has been tapped as
the administration's Point person on AI
apparently to see if artificial
intelligence is no match for her natural
stupidity
and by the way how is she going to help
by Sleeping with R2D2
terrible but hey maybe it's a genius
move to have our most inane human face
off with AI five minutes with Cam would
make a Roomba pull its own plug
today she met with CEOs from major
companies developing AI including Google
Microsoft and anthropic which raises the
question what the hell is anthropic
a subdivision of Hawaiian Tropic
that's funny it is funny so shut up
according to the White House the meeting
was meant to quote underscore this
responsibility and emphasize the
importance of driving responsible
trustworthy and ethical Innovation with
safeguards that mitigate risks and
potential harms to individuals and our
society hell I did an AI to translate
that into English
so it's about short and long-term
dangers of this technology meaning will
they kill us tomorrow or in 10 years and
many dams and Republicans agree it's
good that we finally you know got around
to talking about it but are we really
putting our best foot forward when we
send this
important for
for every moment in time and certainly
this one
moment
in time in which we exist in our present
so during women's history month we
celebrate and we honor the women who
made history
throughout history the significance of
the passage of time right the
significance of the passage of time so
when you think about it there is great
significance to the passage of time it
is time for us to do what we have been
doing in that time is every day
they call that a
Idaho because every time she speaks I'm
waiting for garlic croutons to fall out
of her mouth
I mean can you imagine how that AI
meeting went all those industry heads
would be unplugging their laptops and
using the cords to hang themselves
of course putting cam on the AI team is
all about her gaining new visibility for
the next election which is like
squeegeeing your windshield before
driving off a cliff
I mean we're talking about Kamala the
human Atari 2600 sitting down with
people who've developed complex AI
technology they know what powers the
machines and the only thing she's ever
turned on was Willie Brown wow get
another sexist would say
disgusting
look none of these politicians Know Jack
about technology they embarrass
themselves at those hearings about
social media but this is pure just
giving up you think that creature that
says this even bothers to read up on
anything
I think of this moment as a moment that
is about great momentum
inspired by yes optimism inspired by a
crisis no doubt but inspired by also our
Collective ability to see what can be
unburdened by what has been
quick someone get her a glass of
Thousand Island
but her ramblings aren't a sign of
stupidity it's a sign of arrogance that
she feels exempt from preparation or
substance she'll just wing it on our
biggest challenge the problem is you got
to have talent to wing it you know or
maybe Bongos Vander I have those three
circles right so on this the section
between climate
extreme climate right which is going to
be about that's going to be also an
intersection with human behaviors about
greenhouse gas emissions what we need to
do around carbon capture right
intersection between that public health
and then how we're thinking about in
terms of the intersection between that
and education
never gets old
now
the White House also said they're going
to spend 140 million bucks to create
seven new AI research institutes well
here's the suggestion please don't put
any in Wuhan
and keep them away from this jackass
and the White House budget office which
is as useful as a tourism board in Syria
is expected to issue guidance on how
federal agencies can use AI tools
meaning they'll be taught to audit
taxpayers and perform abortions
which brings us back to the those other
worldwide threats I mean what do you
think the other world powers are gonna
do with AI you know if China's working
on a military angle here's what they're
planning
[Music]
[Applause]
so what will America get with kamalan
charge
[Laughter]
oh
so yeah if you weren't sure we were
screwed before oh we're screwed
but there's one silver lining maybe if
AI gains the upper hand it can replace
Kamala and would we even know the
difference
we have to have courage and if we don't
have courage you're not going to have a
country now we have to win and we have
to win bigger than ever before and we'll
get it all straightened out Elton
Johnson on course are very dangerous you
do a fantastic concert everyone's going
crazy then you do an encore of a song
it's good then you do another Encore and
the song doesn't work and you leave
everyone said what a rotten job
[Laughter]
better than the real thing
[Applause]
he just smells like one host of fox
Across America Jimmy Fallon
born in Oklahoma he's still getting used
to indoor plumbing Terence K Williams
Show Terence K Williams
she stands up for Jews and gives
anti-semites the blues human rights
lawyer and author of the new book and
Jew hatred I wonder what that's about
Brooke goldsey
thank you
and her book guarantees when readers
want most a refund boxes contributor
Jimmy I go to you first because you look
like a pervert florist
[Applause]
um
she's gonna wing this just like she
Wings every this is the worst thing you
can Wing oh a thousand percent isn't it
scary though that we have computers that
can talk like a human but a vice
president who can't yeah but here's a
fun fact about your buddy Jimmy Fallon
did you know I met her husband oh really
in D.C this weekend Douglas eamhoff I
posted a picture of it online very sweet
man way too much Secret Service yeah
that's not my take that's his take he's
like hello I'm married to Kamala kidnap
me you know what I mean
get me out of here but yes it was a
bizarre experience I met her I actually
met kjp too weird as hell the poor
waiter he asked her what she wanted for
dinner she kept going through a binder
for 10 minutes trying to find an answer
um but that one bombed but stick with me
I thought you'd like that one I love it
when you use this show at a workshop new
material look at the jacket I thought
tonight because I look like you like
someone's like you look like you're
going to the Met Gala No I look like I'm
going to the Mets Gala for like fat
Baseball fans that's all I got all right
there you go I guess he had a late night
last night I better believe it uh Brooke
uh nice shirt thank you this is
Shameless promotion of my new book I'm
like reorder it yes and Drew hatred
you're not gonna love our musical guests
awkward don't joke about Jews
chapter one I might throw a pen at you
yes she did that to me many many years
ago do you think kamlo was a good choice
oh absolutely look what she's done to
the border right oh god look this is
such a serious issue okay no matter how
much we joke about it and the best we
have is Elon Musk putting out an open
letter saying that we have to pause but
it's so off if we pause China's not
pausing Iran's not buzzing so that's
actually going to put us in an even
worse position and look at how these
countries are already using their AI
right Iran is now using AI to identify
women who don't have their hijabs on and
there are reports that they're a mass
executing these women after they
identify them we have China that has
their social scores right where they
follow citizens they see how they
operate and they can either have their
rights or they don't have the rights it
is so scary right now and I honestly I
don't even know what to say I'm I'm so
horrified and that is why I live with my
children on a mountain in Northern
Israel with no internet and they live in
cages
what YouTube is let's just hope AI helps
you end Jew hatred oh yeah yeah let's
let's bring it always back to that
Darren so what do you make of this whole
AI thing and her involvement Lord Jesus
Take the Wheel listen
Kamala Harris being in charge of
artificial intelligence I mean that's
like putting Hunter in charge of a rehab
facility
Hillary Clinton in charge of Jeffrey
Epstein's cell
all right come on I think they did yeah
right they did I just don't get it just
like Kamala Harris is the dumbest Vice
President we have ever had just imagine
close your eyes and just imagine
Kamala Harris
pulling up to a meeting laughing and
giggling to sit down in front of some of
the smartest scientists in the country
and then says guys
we have to understand the significance
of AI because when we understand the
significance of AI
we will begin to learn more about the
babe I felt like she was right here yeah
yeah it was real this was the enormous
person in charge like
who else would they have put in charge
featherman like I mean
he could use AI or he was the dude that
stole the luggage Sam Brickman right oh
yeah but I think a robot can do a better
job than Kamala Harris and like she said
Kamala Harris couldn't even take care of
the Border yeah we're gonna put this
laughing hyena in charge of artificial
intelligence we are in trouble yeah we
are we cat welcome to the show you look
very serious you look like your cat Tim
from the future thank you the dress came
with a security clearance
wow you should come with a Podium yeah
yeah I know she looks like the Waffle
House Press Secretary
oh that was a compliment
I'm really skinny
um I don't know I whenever I hear the
government talking about how they need
to do something for safety or security
like alarm Bells go off in my head like
are they gonna use fear to try to you
know get us to be okay with them doing
something I get that some legislation is
going to be necessary but I don't know
when's the last time the government
admitted or limited its legislation to
only what is necessary that could be be
me being paranoid but I don't think so
because I'm looking at every single
other thing that's ever happened ever
but then so by that logic that it's a
good thing that she's in charge perhaps
because she might do nothing yeah yeah
isn't it scary though that we have like
the super intelligent artificial life
that wants to wipe us out and we're
being led by a man who doesn't know why
his VCR is flashing 12 o'clock you know
like that scares me and the only thing I
would add to what he says is like it's
also mind-blowing that in this country
vice president is the only job you can
get if you laugh for no reason during
the interview yeah if you were hiring a
dog walker for Gus and they were like
I'm just going to take him to the park
they'd be like you know what I'll keep
Gus with me for the day because I'm
scared exactly she just reminds me of
the Eternal college student that likes
to party and then sleeps in and then
says you know what I I know I can take
this test yeah yeah and then and and she
got away with it but now she's this is
like an important and it's important she
it's an important thing she reminds me
yeah she sounds like a college student
that's been smoking weed all day yeah
yeah you know what she sounds like she
sounds like the college student at the
aunt from Full House paid to get her
into USC you know
all right before we go tickets are
available for my upcoming book tour look
at that huh look how ripped I am she
didn't know that I'll be in Atlanta
Clearwater Fort Myers Providence that's
in Rhode Island and my favorite Reading
Pennsylvania
home of the peanut bar anybody been to
the peanut bar no you can eat peanuts in
there and then just leave it on the
floor if you get a customized Mother's
Day card when you pre-order the book and
go to gcutfeld.com for details hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else